NARRATOR: While the rivers
and ponds are melting,
the ground remains frozen.
And under the leaf
litter, someone
is pulling off a miracle.
[intriguing music]
This wood frog is frozen solid.
Even his eyes are iced over.
There's no pulse, no breath.
Slowly the warmth
of spring begins
to thaw, from the inside out.
His heart starts beating.
[dramatic music]
His brain lights up--
[intriguing music]
-- and he begins to move.
It turns out that
the frog's liver
pumped a syrupy, natural
antifreeze into his cells
in the fall.
It kept his organs
from freezing.
Only the water
between cells froze.
After eight months frozen,
he's completely undamaged,
and leaping straight
for the nearest pond.
[water splashing]
Now, Alaska's least welcome
yearly arrival slowly
bursts from its watery home--
the mosquito.
[intriguing music]
And it immediately wants blood.
Not even cold-blooded
frogs are immune.
The number of mosquitoes
here far outstrips
that in any jungle on earth.
[music continues]
[water splashing]
[mosquitoes buzzing]